[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GARY GENSLER:
Welcome to FinTech--
Shaping the Future of
The World of Finance.
And happy spring.
It's May.
I thought what the heck?
You've got to be a
little innovative.
Try teaching from outdoor.
So this is not a
virtual backdrop.
If the sun is too much or
the birds are too much,
that's an additional thing
Romain can give me advice on.
Now today we're going to dive
into insurance and technology
or what some call this little
sector of fintech as insurtech.
But it's not so
little, it's not just
simply because the excitement is
around payments and challenger
banks and apps like Robinhood
and the capital markets
and so forth that we leave
insurtech to the end.
I also think insurtech
is an interesting field
that it brings all the
pieces together in some way.
It brings together
a part of finance
that has big legacy incumbents.
In every country
we're in, there is
this handful of life-insurance
companies and property
and casualty insurance--
that's those that offer lines
of insurance on our homes,
our autos, and so forth;
health-care insurers,
particularly
in those countries that
have, like the US, big,
open health-care systems.
These insurance companies,
big, legacy companies,
have tended to be a little
behind the curve of technology
compared to the
Wall Street firms--
not a lot behind
but a little behind.
And then the insurtech itself,
the fintech within insurance,
has done some really
interesting things particularly
around alternative data, and
we're going to dive into some
of these opportunities.
And also they're a little bit
new forms of alternative data.
It's not just about
our credit weighting.
It's about our driving.
It's about our homes.
It's about thinking about can
we underwrite insurance risk
related to how we live our
lives, how we drive our cars,
how small businesses
are operated,
and whether there's more
information that can be brought
to bear or not just financial
inclusion but the pricing
and underwriting of risk?
Of course, we're going
to see the same trends
about artificial intelligence.
We're going to see some really
important trends around user
interfaces.
And one of the most interesting
areas around user interfaces
is what's called
claims management,
an area that hopefully you don't
have to think about too much.
But amongst this
class of 80 or more,
I'm sure that somebody has had
a little fender bender, had
some scrape up on the roads.
And now that there are
apps that you can just,
on your mobile phone, take
some quick photographs
and put it right
into the system.
Claims management is changing
quite a bit now as well,
and there's startups in
this space that basically
say we will get you better
claims management faster,
smoother, and a better user
experience about claims
management.
So with that, I'm going to try
to upload the slides again.
We can join sort
of the community
together, sort of videos on.
Please raise your
hands actively.
Romain's going to be watching
for any blue hands up
also in the chat.
And if the birds
get to be too much,
just know that I'll go
back inside on Wednesday.
Romain, how is it so far?
TEACHING ASSISTANT: It's fine.
It's very nice.
Don't worry.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
He's assuring me that
I can keep having
a little bit of
an indulgence here
in this beautiful
outdoor setting.
And what I'm going to need to
do is go to this Share Screens.
So we're going to talk
a little bit-- we're
going to start a little bit
about the insurance value
chain and the sector's
landscape now.
And traditionally
in business schools,
traditionally in worlds of
finance and finance majors,
there's a lot of time spent on
banking and on capital markets,
and there's some time but
less time spent on insurance.
And so I'm going to just lay
the groundwork a little bit
about insurance, some
of the challenges
in the sector itself, and
then get into this field
fintech and insurance
or what a lot of people
call insurtech, opportunities,
business models,
and the startups.
So that's sort of the
goal of the class.
The readings were really
about this area of insurtech.
There was a handful of them.
The Bank of
International Settlement
reading was really
talking about some
of the regulatory challenges
and whether insurtech
will change some of the risks in
terms of regulating this space.
And then a little
reading about Asia.
And if you've not had
the opportunity to look
at some of the readings
because they were just put up
last Friday, go back.
Sort of dive.
Take a little look.
And again, we'll
see if anybody wants
to give a little
view in this field,
but what opportunities in the
current insurance sector--
or what are the pain
points, you think,
that you might
want to highlight?
And again, this is just to
get a little conversation go.
So Romain?
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
OK, here we go.
Who will be our first
volunteer for today?
GARY GENSLER: Has anybody
ever had insurance and felt
there was a little pain point?
Michael, I see a hand up.
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
As always, Michael
is helping us out
to get us started.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think one
of the obvious ones
is just processing time.
It's just really kind
of through each step
of the process, underwriting--
I don't know-- processing,
completing, [INAUDIBLE],,
it just takes a long time.
So kind of there's
definitely a lot
of opportunities for automatic
feedback or leveraging AI
to really speed that
up for consumers.
GARY GENSLER: So the two sides
of processing-- it's the front
and when you're actually
trying to get your insurance,
when you're actually--
it's called underwriting.
The insurance company is
pricing and giving you
availability of insurance.
And whether it's
life insurance where
you might have to send
in some medical tests
and the like,
homeowners insurance,
renters insurance,
auto insurance
where there's a process
going on at the front end.
And then there's
also the process
if you have an accident.
Insurance is this product
that basically if you never
hear from your insurance company
and they never hear from you,
you've paid a premium to
protect you against a risk,
but the risk has not
generated a loss.
But then you have the accident.
Then you have the problem.
Then you have to
send in a claim.
And that process
on the back end,
the insurance companies want
to protect against fraud.
They want to fulfill
your claim, but they
want to protect
against fraud, and
the claim-adjustment process
is a significant time
and human and paper-based
and sometimes legal-based
circumstance.
So, Michael, you're right.
Pain points at the front
end, particular pain points
in the claims-processing side.
Anything else you
want to throw in?
AUDIENCE: I guess--
GARY GENSLER: Oh, we've got a
few other hands if you want.
I mean if you want to--
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
I can pass it off
to somebody else.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Alessandro?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think another big trend
is we're going to see
different type of insurances
come to life as more and
more risks are becoming
quantifiable.
And this leads to a
number of events or things
we can get insurance on.
So the selection of things
on which we can get insured
is going to increase
dramatically
because the quantifiable risks
are getting bigger and bigger.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
And sometimes it's not
just a new risk in society
but it's, as Alexandro is
saying, the quantifiability
of it.
So let's take auto
insurance and a company that
started a number of years
ago called Metromile.
Simple concept-- what if we
charged automobile insurance
not by the month but
maybe by the mile?
Could we quantify that
you've only driven a mile
and that would be the insurance?
And if you're a heavy
driver, there's more.
And, in fact, what if the
mile is out on the country
roads or it's
actually in the cities
and where you're driving?
So quantifiability, the
analytics, the computer
capability, but also the
connections to all of us
with sensors and the
internet of things.
So I've sort of given a
little bit of a preview,
but there were some
other hands up.
How have that which we've
talked about all semester--
machine learning,
alternative data--
influenced this?
But a new factor that
we've really not talked
much about in banking and
challenger banks and payment
systems is the
internet-of-things devices
possibly changing the
field of insurance.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Danielle,
would you like to go.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
And also you just broke up
there, so if you lose me,
sorry about my
internet connection.
So there's an opportunity
for the insurance landscape
to be changed by alternative
data in that companies can now
inform their underwriting
process with a lot
more information, a
lot richer set of data
than they previously had.
So whereas for health
insurance or life insurance
you might have had to
fill out a survey--
people are varying
degrees of honest on those
kinds of surveys.
Now we're suddenly generating
an extremely accurate picture
of ourselves almost passively by
everything we do in the world,
and companies can
access that information.
GARY GENSLER: Right,
or can they access it?
They still have
to have a network.
And what's really
interesting in this space
is that just as we
saw a data aggregation
an important feature in the
payment space with companies
like Plaid and
Galileo and everything
that they were right
there collecting
data between the banks
and the payment systems
and then hundreds or
thousands of fintech startups,
that there were data
aggregators in the middle,
there are data
aggregators in this field
as well to collect that
data, commercialize the data,
but maybe stand between
our lives and all
the sensors and
data-collection efforts
and hundreds or thousands of
startups on the other side
as well.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Nikhil?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I think this is more specific
to the health-insurance side
of things where a lot
of times in health
insurance, 90% of claims
are auto adjudicated,
and most of them are based
on statistical methods.
With the influx of AI,
you can review claims
that you weren't
reviewing before,
and so you could potentially
uncover more fraud, waste,
and abuse than you were.
So this is a market that
they haven't sized yet
because they don't know
how big fraud might be.
So I think there's a
big trend there as well.
GARY GENSLER: Great point.
And sometimes it's not truly
artificial intelligence
or machine learning.
It's just the remarkable ability
to collect, sort, clean up
the data, standardize
the data that might also
have a bit of machine
learning on top of it,
but it doesn't have to
be the machine learning.
It's sort of this partnering up.
And then what are some
of the challenges?
We're going to talk about
some of the challenges
for the startups trying to get
in there-- capital, regulation.
And does anybody have a
view as to the date why
we haven't seen--
with some important
exceptions, but we
haven't seen big
tech firms getting
engaged in the insurance field.
Now, there's some
important exceptions
we'll talk about in
China, by the way,
but why we haven't seen Amazon--
they're in the credit-card
space-- and Apple
in payment space but why
we haven't seen big tech,
by and large.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Laira?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I just
think that it's mostly
because there's a lot
of barriers to entry,
namely as you mentioned,
regulation and also
lack of expertise, which all
of these insurance companies
already have.
So I think it's also regulation
and high costs because of lack
of expertise that prevents these
big tech firms from entering
into the insurance market.
GARY GENSLER: All right, so
I think that's partly right,
but I'm also going to
put out the question
throughout the class and a
thought experience at the end,
is it just that we
haven't gotten there yet?
Is it a possibility that--
again, big tech is about data,
networks, and activities,
as the Bank of International
Settlement has written.
And so do they want to
layer another activity
upon that network--
upon that network?
We haven't quite seen it.
I said that with one
important exception in China.
In China a number of
years ago, big tech--
Alibaba, Tencent
that has WeChat--
partnered up with one
of the largest insurance
companies in China,
and the three of them
started effectively
an insurtech.
It's the world's
largest insurtech
if we still call it that,
and it was owned and operated
by three very big companies.
Ping An was the
insurance company.
And so it wasn't direct.
It was a joint venture.
But it's a question
of will we see this
coming into the future or not?
So let's just sort of
dive into the value chain.
You've got to design a product.
You've got to market it.
It goes all the way
to claims management.
You can be in any
one of these pieces.
This is just pulled from
the Federal Insurance
Office of the US Department
of Treasury from a report
last year.
But each of these pieces might
have a piece of competition
and a pain point.
We talked a little bit
about claims management.
Claims management
separates insurance
from the banking
fintech we've talked
about, but a lot
of the underwriting
and the front end--
designing a product
and the marketing--
you'll see that an
awful lot of disruption
is going on at that front end.
Marketing is sales.
It's brokerage.
It's bringing in the customer.
It's a better user interface,
a better user experience.
In the underwriting
and rating side,
you can underwrite credit.
You can underwrite insurance.
It's basically how
much insurance will
I provide to whom at what price?
And that underwriting
process ultimately
comes to administering the
policy and then the claims
management side of it.
So each of these pieces
of the value chain
might have pain points.
The front four of these,
designing products
to policy administration,
actually has a lot of overlap
with the banking sector--
not identical.
Important differences.
So what's this sector look like?
I just list companies on
these several next slides--
life insurance,
property, casualty.
What I want you to take out
of is not particular names
in your country, whether it's
China Life or MetLife or Nippon
Life and Swiss Life.
It's that if you look at when
these companies were founded,
many are 20th century, but
many are actually 19th century.
The concentration
and the survival
the persistence of
insurance companies
is quite consistent
around the globe.
They talk about the big five
in China, but in any country--
in any country there's a
handful of insurance companies.
Once you get to about the
top 10, you're at 85% to 90
plus percent market
share, particularly
in life insurance and property
and casualty-- a little less so
in some other fields.
And there's, of course,
health and managed care.
More a feature of the
US health-care system
where it's private insurance.
And then big diversified
companies across the globe.
Diversified simply means that
it's both in life and property
and casualty and the like.
So it's multiline.
But let's not forget there's
also reinsurance and then
brokers, and the brokerage side
is an area where disruptors
have started to say, well,
maybe we can broker insurance.
And by brokering insurance,
it's basically making the sales,
making the marketing,
but not taking the risk
onto your own balance sheet--
benefits administration,
software.
The only companies that
are 21st-century companies
on this whole sort of review
is in the software and services
side of things.
So that's kind of my
kind of overall point.
US insurance premiums,
just to give you
a sense of scale the market,
about $1 and 1/2 trillion
a year.
We talk about the
finance sector that's
about $7 and 1/2
trillion in the US--
I'm sorry, 7 and 1/2%--
7 and 1/2% of GDP--
overstatement there-- which
is about $1 and 1/2 trillion.
This is consistent
with that size.
These are the
premiums being paid
into direct premiums written.
The health and life
side of things, just
to give you a little flavor--
and these will all be
on Canvas, of course.
By and large, a big part
of the life and health side
is savings products.
There's competition between
life companies and banks,
life companies and
investment-management companies
on the annuity side.
The disruption, so to speak,
has been happening largely
in property and casualty.
But to the extent that insurtech
starts to get into this space,
I think you will see
more and more disruption
in the savings-products
side as well.
The companies like Betterment
and all those companies
we talked about in the
wealth-management side
or in wealthtech I think you
will see starting to say, wait.
Maybe we can get
into the annuity side
as well, the annuity
and savings side
of life-insurance products.
Property and casualty,
just a little breakdown
here in the US.
And so now we turn to
challenges, pain points.
What do we have?
This is true of any
incumbent company.
You could be a company
that's been in business
for a hundred-plus
years, and you're
sitting there going I'm selling
through an agent or broker
network.
And the agency and brokerage
network here in the US
takes a big chunk of fees.
I think on the
property/casualty side,
we're probably in the 10% to
13% of premiums on average.
But in some products, it's much
larger, some a little smaller.
The life side, the premiums I
think are in high single digits
to 10% on average.
And while I'm not sort of an
expert of all the fee, that
basically means if you pay
$1,000 for your auto insurance,
$100 plus, $120 is being taken
by those agents and brokers.
Claims administration,
we talked about it.
Very paper and human intensive.
Litigation risk all abound.
Insurance companies are built
up around this legacy tech,
just like in payments
and in credit.
Of every dollar of premium,
a big chunk is not only
going to the agents
and the brokers
but a big chunk is
going, of course,
to the whole claims processing
and the whole value chain.
And because it's deeply
regulated, in many marketplaces
you can't offer a
new type of insurance
without getting some
official sector approval.
Going through the
product-design phase
often has legacy and
time delays within it.
And, of course, just
like the other fields,
there's whole sorts of questions
about user interface and user
experience.
All of these present
challenges, but they also
present opportunities.
Romain, any questions?
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
Not yet, but let's
wait perhaps a few seconds.
No, I don't see any hands up.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So insurance and
insurance tech--
you can sort of say
I want to be involved
in the pricing and underwriting,
the quotes, the policy
administration, the claims
management, sort of four
different sectors, improving
the customer engagement,
lowering operating costs.
Look, of course it
always goes back
to can you do something
better, quicker, cheaper?
But as we talked about earlier,
it could be in product design
as well.
It could be in not just
doing it cheaper in pricing
but more availability and,
as Metromile has done, really
in using metrics to get
to a new type of product
itself and the quoting
and issuing of products.
So what are some of
the opportunities
more specifically?
I think across
financial technology,
it's about user interface
and user experience.
So that could be
on the sales side.
It can be in the
account management,
digital and mobile
phones, but also
in the conversational interface.
Underwriting, we've talked
about it, really not just
the machine learning but
the alternative data,
and then claims processing.
I think these are the big three.
They seem pretty
simple once I say it.
But it's sort of like
thinking about it,
and if you have
a business model,
if you're going
into this business
or you're at Prudential
Life Insurance or Nippon
Life, it's sort of saying,
how can we use technology
to enhance user experience?
How can we enhance basically
the pricing and the availability
of our product underwriting?
How do we do the back end?
The first two, user
experience and underwriting,
very much true in banking tech.
Claims processing,
somewhat unique here.
And it's about data capture.
Now, one part of
the data capture--
and you can see it here--
drones, the internet of things,
smartphones, telematics,
wearables.
I'm curious-- Romain,
you'll see if anyone
will raise their hand.
Has anybody actually
taken insurance
where the insurance company
has said for your automobile,
we want to have access
to your driving record
directly through your
car's telematics?
Telematics is a word that didn't
exist 30 and 50 years ago,
or if it did exist, it
wasn't commonly used.
It's about all the information
that your car is collecting
on driving in the computers
on board your car,
and it's not just GPS.
And it can sort of
assess your driving.
Smartphones as well can assess
our driving because smartphones
are not just locational devices,
but they can get all the ups
and downs of your driving.
What does that mean?
That between smartphones
and the computers
on our cars, a
product can be offered
that says we know enough
about your driving
that we will give you fine-tuned
pricing and underwriting.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Danielle?
GARY GENSLER: Romain?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I had a
question around Google's deal
with Ascension to store and
analyze the medical records
from their hospital network.
And I'm curious if you
think that kind of entrance,
the big tech into
the medical world,
is going to be more
common and if that might
be a potential avenue for those
kinds of companies getting
the insight into
health data that they
would need to make
them confident to move
into insurance?
GARY GENSLER: I
think you've landed
upon one area that big tech
can be very influential,
particularly the big AI
companies like Google and Baidu
in China, to the extent--
and we'll see there
are some startups that
are entering this field because
they're very good at data
analytics and machine learning.
And to the extent
that they can be
data aggregators like Google,
you're absolutely right.
I don't think it's just
health care, by the way,
but I think health care is a
really important piece of it,
that many insurance companies,
health-care management
companies in the US have a
tremendous amount of data,
and they want to make
more sense of it.
And they want to,
with that data,
provide more fine-tuned
insurance products
but also help manage our
health-care system better.
So I think it is an avenue for
certain big tech companies that
are at the cutting edge of data
analytics and machine learning.
Not for every big tech company
but for many I agree with that.
Did anybody have an insurance--
did anybody take out
an auto insurance?
TEACHING ASSISTANT: I
think probably Alessandro.
He had his hand up but
probably for a question.
AUDIENCE: I had this little
chip or a computer on board.
And basically, yeah,
it traced everything
that I did with the car, like
where I was, how many miles I
drove, everything.
And it actually helped me to
decrease the cost of insurance.
GARY GENSLER: There you go.
There you go.
Now, some of the first
patents filed on telematics
were in the late 1990s.
But what we found is
it's really changed
the field of auto insurance.
This little visualization
about insurtech,
again from the Department
of Treasury study last fall,
I think is just a good
place to pause for a second.
We're not going to
go through every box,
but whether it's
sensors and telematics--
and this is a big piece
of having those sensors
and telematics there to lower
Alexandro's cost of insurance
but also for claims management.
If the telematics and sensors
are there upon an accident,
then you can lower a little bit
the cost of claims management,
and the insurance companies
can have confidence
the accident actually happened,
potentially figure out
who's at fault, see right
at that moment what's
going on in that automobile.
Visual computing,
literally downloading,
uploading photographs into
the claims management process.
We've already talked about
machine learning and AI,
but blockchain technology
I want to touch upon.
Of all the fields of
blockchain technology
that we generally have
heard about-- and many of
them are hype versus reality.
One field is whether with the
use of blockchain technology
that we can have an
append-only log that
is tamper resistant
whether there would
be trust in a field of insurance
called parametric insurance.
In essence, if we had an
automated smart contract
that said that if this
happens, I get paid.
So what's the this?
One field that a group of
students studied last year,
studying it on behalf
of a group in Asia,
was parametric insurance
for airline delays.
If you could embed on a
tamper-resistant ledger.
On that ledger, you would
embed smart contracts
that says if the plane takes off
more than a half hour late, you
automatically get paid.
A mobile app.
No trying to rely
on the airlines
whether they're
accurately telling you
or not that the
plane took off late.
Put it on a
blockchain technology.
Now, maybe you could do it with
a central database as well,
but there are many
people looking
to whether to use
blockchain technology
for parametric insurance.
But the sensors and telematics,
the visual computing,
the machine learning,
those are real.
The Department of
Treasury sort of also put
something on the edge in terms
of blockchain technology.
Challenges though
abound for insurtech.
There's still the age-old
challenge of funding.
And it's particularly
true in insurance
because if you take an insurance
risk onto your balance sheet,
that's a liability of
an insurance company.
That's a liability
that in the future
they have to pay out a
claim on an accident, a loss
on your home, or on your life.
So many companies are
finding challenges.
If they're startups, how
can they access capital?
Now in the banking
sector, you can possibly
do it through securitization.
You can basically
say I'm not going
to build my own balance sheet.
I'm going to sort of
rent a balance sheet.
I'm going to lay it off.
Similarly here, you can lay off
some risk in the reinsurance
markets, but it's
not quite the same
for these insurtech startups.
Most challenger banks
partner with some bank,
get a warehouse line of
credit, and possibly also then
sell their loans after
they're initiated.
Here, it's not as robust.
It's not as developed.
But again, many insurance
fintech startups
are saying do I partner with a
big, dominant insurance company
because I can't build my
balance sheet as rapidly?
If you choose to be a carrier--
and a carrier is the term to say
you actually take the insurance
onto your balance sheet.
You have the liability.
Choose to be a carrier, it's
balance-sheet intensive.
Also, just how do you find
your startup run-rate loss
because all the
startups tend to have
multiple years of
building out a network
and building the
platform itself.
Clearly the
competitive landscape,
the regulatory frameworks--
the regulatory frameworks,
do you get licensed?
Again, similar to
the challenger banks.
Remember we talked about
there's neobanks and challenger
banks which often people sort
of say in the same breath
they're the same.
But more specifically,
a neobank is
something doing a lot
of banking functions
that has not yet gotten
a banking license.
Similar here, if you're thinking
about starting an insurance
fintech firm, what type
of licensing will you get?
Will it just be a
brokerage licensing?
In various
jurisdictions, you have
to register to be a
broker or an agent.
Are you actually registering
to take lines onto your balance
sheet and become a carrier?
And then, of course, user
adoption and the use of data.
And in terms of the
use of data, there
aren't quite the same laws.
We have the same
conceptual framework
that you have to be
fair and unbiased,
but there aren't
quite the same laws
like the Equal Credit
Opportunity Act here in the US.
And in terms of the use of
data, as we'll see in a minute,
if you sign a waiver and say
you can use my driving record
to give my insurance,
is Alexandro did,
they can use that data also
on the claims-management side.
It's not just to lower the cost.
It's also to see, if you
call up and say an accident,
they look at the telematics and
say, did this really happen?
So the insurtech landscape--
we're not going to dive
into this slide, but it's
just each of these pieces--
each of these
pieces, it might be
that you're trying to go into
the billing and payments, which
is sort of rudimentary, sort of.
You could be going all
the way to another area
and say we're going
to be the best data
analytics on wearables.
And by I mean wearables, how
many people have a Fitbit?
Does anybody want to talk
about whether you've signed up
for insurance that
your insurance company
can get your data
off of your Fitbit
or off of your Apple watch?
What you're using
for exercise can
lower your cost of insurance.
I'm going to pause, Romain.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: I
don't see any hands up.
Lindsay, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, I didn't
have like the agreement
with the insurance,
but what I did have
is that my former employer had
a program where we would connect
our tracking devices
like for steps and stuff
with this program that
would give you kickbacks
if you got so many steps a day.
So I'd get tons of gift cards
because of all the steps
I tracked in.
And that data I'm sure was
going to the insurance company
to lower the insurance rates.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
So if you got to your
10,000 steps-- or maybe
they gave you a premium
for 5,000 steps.
You got some rewards.
We all know about rewards
programs in credit cards,
and that's part of that 2
and 3/4% interchange fees.
These rewards by your
employer, ultimately
the economic incentives
is the employer
can have lower cost
of health insurance.
That data through
the intermediation
of your employment contract was
lowering health-insurance costs
for some group health insurance.
Now, I think your
employer was also
doing it because they know if
you're a better health that you
also have fewer days off.
You'll be hopefully
a better employee.
So they're also lowering
some of their costs
in terms of their direct
costs, but it also
relates to health insurance.
So wearables, trackables,
telematics, and the internet
of thing.
The internet of thing
is about sensors.
And it's about sensors in many
items in our home as well.
If you have a home
security system,
in the last 5 or
10 years, you've
been able to tie
that into more data.
Now, home security systems
have for decades somehow
had to communicate
through a security company
to the law enforcement
if the alarm went off,
but I'm talking about
more fine-tune monitoring.
And we all are aware, even
though that very few of us
might have it, that you
can have apps on your phone
that you can communicate
with your home
to turn on your heat or
your air conditioning,
monitor your home,
home-monitoring devices that
makes all of us maybe
more comfortable
that our home is
secure or even to have
the communication from the
home if, for some reason,
there is a problem in the home.
And there's sensors
on refrigerators.
There's sensors on HVAC,
heating and ventilation systems.
There are sensors
throughout houses.
The 2020s, we're going to see
this just absolutely mushroom
in terms of sensors.
So what's that data do
for the insurance field?
That's why I think insurtech
and insurance and fintech
is such an exciting and
interesting place because we
are basically in a
transformational time
right now in terms of sensor
technology and embedding
sensors into our economies
not because of insurance
but because many users
want to sort of monitor
either their home, their
automobile, their wearable,
their trackable.
And now with this
really challenging time
around the coronavirus
crisis, we're
talking about contact tracing.
And all that contact
tracing could also
be fed in, depending
upon the jurisdiction,
depending upon the regulation,
into health-insurance rates,
life-insurance rates, or
any form of insurance.
Again, largely dependent upon
the various jurisdictions'
regulatory and legal frameworks.
So what are some of
the possibilities?
You can become a
licensed insurer.
That means actually
committing balance sheet,
becoming licensed, taking
claims on as a liability,
managing the asset side as well.
You can be a managed
general agent.
Think broker.
This is just a term to
say you could be managing
agents or brokerage or sales.
Those are kind of
the two big divides.
But you could just be
on the technology side
or the data-aggregation side.
These are the various
models for insurtech.
Some of the startups-- we won't
go through each one of them,
but you're going to see a
common thing in these lists is,
by and large, all
founded in the 20-teens.
So this is 5 or 10
years of dynamic change.
You're going to
see heavy emphasis
on homeowners and autos.
So it's in the consumer
space, very similar to credit.
You see a little bit moving
into small business but not
large commercial lines,
though Bold Penguin
is a commercial
insurance exchange.
A lot is on the front end.
And on the auto side, you also
get marketplace comparisons,
just like in the credit space.
It's basically Expedia
for auto insurance, so
to speak you could say,
or Expedia for fill
in the blank insurance.
These are the
marketplace comparisons
like CoverHound and Goji.
But throughout, you'll
see home and auto,
small business is
kind of the dominant.
Has anybody used the product
Lemonade for renters insurance?
Wow.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: I
don't see any hands up.
GARY GENSLER: Nobody.
So Lemonade got into
the field basically
to say so many people,
particularly in the US,
are renting, and we just want
some insurance for our objects
and our things in our homes
in case there's a problem.
Or maybe the landlord says you
have to have renters insurance.
PolicyBazaar-- PolicyBazaar,
about 12 years old,
one of the largest marketplace
comparison in India.
It is a remarkable platform.
Again, think, broadly speaking,
Expedia for health and life
insurance where you
can price compare--
PolicyBazaar.
Of these various companies--
just pause a bit on Root.
Root uses telematics to
price their products.
Almost every one of the
auto companies on here
are using telematics
and smartphones.
Some of them started
on telematics,
some started more on
the smartphone side,
but the merger of those two.
Tractable in the auto field is
about claims management, just
solely sort of focusing there.
And I said I was going
to mention about China,
the last on this
list, and I probably
will mispronounce how to say it.
ZhongAn was formed by
three very large companies.
Online property and
casualty in China.
It's gone public since.
It's a very significant
company in China.
It's the only online
insurance company
that got licensing in China.
So it chose to get licensing.
It had the backing of
three very large companies
seven years ago.
It got said licensing, and
it has a certain advantage.
To my knowledge, I don't think
anybody else has been there.
So it gives you some
of the smattering.
I'm going to pause, Romain, to
see if there's any questions.
Are we good?
TEACHING ASSISTANT: I
think we're good, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: Health care--
health-care fintech.
I'd still call it insurtech.
Some people can
call it healthtech.
This is the insurance
side and how technology
is coming in to disrupt.
Again, you could be
in any piece of this.
I borrowed this
chart FT partners,
but you could be in
any piece of this
and say I'm going to
do the payments side.
I'm going to do the claims side.
I'm going to be in
benefits management,
but any piece of this.
Again, most of these are in
the US but not all, just some
of what we're seeing.
American Well is about
telehealth, a very important
thing now that we're
in a period of time
that we can't visit
our doctors in person.
Again, you'll see most--
not all of these--
are in the last 10 years.
Clover, which is a unicorn--
almost all of these--
not all of these
are unicorns, meaning worth
over a billion dollars.
Clover is about taking
our analytics about how
we live our lives and trying
to underwrite and lower
the cost to us.
Probably the largest
ones are Bright Health,
which is selling Medicare
Advantage in the US.
On top of Medicare, which
is government provided,
you can have an
augmented program on top
called Medicare Advantage.
Bright Health, Clover, Gusto.
You'll see also there's a
significant number of companies
that have got into the
benefit administration.
This is working with
small businesses
to administer their benefits.
Zenefits that was
formed in 2013--
by 2015, we actually
used Zenefits
on an effort I was involved with
as CFO of the Hillary Clinton
campaign.
It was a two-year-old
startup, and we
decided to go with benefits
because we could outsource
to this vendor our benefits
administration for our startup.
Now, that startup ultimately
proved unsuccessful,
as you know.
But over the course of
time, 5,000 employees,
all that benefit administration,
the health care and so forth,
Zenefits.
HealthEquity is in this
field through health savings
accounts.
HealthEquity actually
bought in the last two years
a company called
WageWorks that I was--
when WageWorks was a startup
company, I went on their board
and managed the hiring
of a CFO and helped
WageWorks prepare to go
public as a private company
as a fintech years ago.
HealthEquity bought
that company, WageWorks.
Gusto is very significant
in this field as well.
So you have a sense, it's the
marrying of finance and health.
So it can be
through the benefits
and payroll-administration
side, which is finance,
or it can be directly
marketplace comparisons like
GoHealth, which is similar
to PolicyBazaar in India--
all of these little
subsectors and slices.
Data related is sort of
the last little slice.
And this goes to
the earlier question
about Google and health care.
While we haven't
seen big tech there,
I think that we're bound to
because there's so many data
analytic.
Cambridge Mobile
Telematics do not-- please
don't confuse with Cambridge
Analytica but Cambridge Mobile
Telematics.
You can see there are
data aggregators that
are collecting telematic data.
They're not alone.
And then with that data,
commercializing it to insurance
companies, big insurance
companies as well as startups.
StrongArm Tech, one of my
favorites in this field--
they're selling a
product that in factories
if your factory workers will
wear some wearable-- not
a Fitbit.
Some of it's like around
the midchest range.
But if they'll
wear a sensor, you
can lower the cost of
workplace insurance.
You can also, hopefully,
make the workplace safer.
So they're selling a safety
device, injury protection,
but it's about
software and hardware
because they're
selling the wearables.
And it's called StrongArm Tech.
Will it be successful?
It's been around nine years.
So what you're seeing
in insurance tech, which
I think is so fascinating and
potentially transformative, is
a whole world of sensors and
collecting alternative data,
whether it's from our cars back
to the telematics, whether it's
from our watches or our
wearables, our Fitbits,
from our smartphones, from the
sensors in our homes, all that
can sort of collect data,
a little bit of machine
learning-- not
always deep machine
learning, deep learning,
but some machine learning.
Lower the costs, broaden
the inclusion potentially.
And then on the
claims-management side
as well, sensor technology,
collecting the data,
lowering the fraud,
and the like.
There's one firm that brags
that they have the shortest
claim-settlement period,
that an online app was
able to get claims settlement
down to less than minutes.
And I think there was one claim
that was settled in seconds.
It was an automobile accident.
It was something they could do
quite quickly technologically,
but I also think that it was
a bit of a marketing thing,
that they wanted to say
you could get claims
management down to minutes.
So that sort of is a
little bit of review.